hey guys what's up i'm walking into my
youtube studio right now where i'm gonna
show you how to make a hundred thousand
dollars a week on youtube we got five
and a half million subscribers even this
loser learned how to do it hey come over
here it's three easy steps number one
okay
what's a goat gun you might ask well
you're about to find out it's how
farmers used to spread goats around
their
goal how do you think the goats get up
on the cliffs there
oh my pirate replica
all right let's see what one they're
different it's got these tiny bullets
the next tiny gun video tiny guns two
yeah i need guns too tinier gun slightly
tiny slightly tiny two guns two tiny two
guns
slightly larger it's slightly more
dangerous
this is pretty inefficient
this is pretty realistic actually more
danger more tiny
she's got a tiny little magazine dude
don't say the word magazine you're gonna
get demonetized
this amateur then i ripped the
instructions in half the moment i touch
them because my hands are so strong my
mom said it's cool if you come over and
play
hey you guys want to come to the studio
at like four and play for a bit with me
okay
hey guys
freeze
freeze
oh wow is that a one-third scale replica
goat gun no go go go go go go go done
i've been waiting like a kid for
christmas for corridors network upgrade
day and it's finally here niko's going
to tell you all about it right now
every morning i walk through this why
are you holding a plant
every morning i walk in the store my
heart swells with pride looking at all
these productive people all these
artists all these filmmakers making
content for you the viewer to entertain
you and move you and teach you and
anything else you're watching the videos
for i don't know miscellaneous items the
problem is is that we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
computers not even counting the laptop
or the 3d printer and our network speed
is only one gigabit so what does that
mean let's say we downloaded a movie off
of torrent website because pirates over
here and we put that on our server and
we wanted to transfer it to my computer
so i could watch it that would take
currently on the system maybe two
minutes or so not that bad on this new
system we're gonna get it's gonna take
12 seconds let's say we want to edit a
video that we shot on our red camera
everybody in the network wants to edit
at the same time that data gets split up
each one of these computers they're all
working off the network at the same time
would have the speed of one computer
working off the current network all by
itself our server has a bunch of hard
drives in it that goes out here into our
network switch it's a one gigabit
network switch and it's time to get that
upgraded we got all these past computers
ryan's got his speedy puget system sam
just got his speedy puget system i'm sad
because i don't have a speedy puget
system yet what what am i doing here
today we are being visited by our friend
kim from uia solutions kim specializes
in networking data management and all
these things that sound really boring
but are actually really cool and very
important so hopefully this will all fix
the solutions this is the 10 gig switch
went with a 48 port allows us to have
every single port in this office to be
able to do 10 gig this is a network card
that will be going into each individual
workstation which allows us to connect
to the server through 10 gig right the
goal today is to hopefully upgrade this
entire office into 10 gig networking
which will allow us to edit files
transfer files in no time at all right
let's go dude we're here today at the 10
times growth summit
chance for media buyers to learn more
about what we do they've invited us down
here to speak to them hopefully it's an
opportunity where we can explain in
detail do add better i'm nico perringer
you dude nico
and a bit of a moral dilemma because i
don't know on the banner it says and on
all the flyers it says it says making
your videos look like a million bucks
without a million bucks they're more
tailored to
creators than it is to
buyers of advertisement so the question
is should i talk about that
or should i talk about what i was going
to talk about which is more about how to
brand videos
i believe in you
thanks man
thank
you the reason for somebody just not
walking into like a regular place that
has network connections and why is it
not 10 gig the two big things are is
having the infrastructure to be able to
handle 10 gig right for example cat 5e
which is standard throughout the us
isn't capable of doing 10 games and the
next part say cost 10 gig equipment is
super expensive it's quite new
technology it hasn't fallen down to
consumers mostly data center type things
right so kim the last thing here before
we jump in yeah what made you want to
get into networking your company things
like that it's all started just messing
around with computers we mess around
mess around and after a while you're
like things could go faster right
i think the first thing i thought about
was like steam games right i was curious
if you could put a steam game on servers
so you can just just have a server
somewhere and play your game from
anywhere right it's like that that's
something interesting and research
research and then after a while we're
like doesn't work well don't have 10
games
we realized that a lot of studios were
still in the stone age right let's put
it that way they had a hard drive they
recorded on it they put it on and then
each each editor got a hard drive or
something right then boom somebody drops
a hard drive everybody cries
we wanted to provide a solution that
allowed primarily the editors and and
creative developers to be able to
utilize these type of solutions to allow
them to have an easier life you don't
have to sit and wait all day for your
file to transfer all right let's open
these boxes
damn son look at all these terabits are
these the 12 terabyte ones they're only
the eight
i am offended sir dude that's 12 times
eight that's 96 terabytes 96 terabytes
oh my god oh that's just the back up
wait i think we're only a few years out
from a petabyte guys but we're not linus
i've been waiting like a kid for
christmas for network upgrade day at
corridor and it's finally here
i need some stuff
i'm like right in the middle of editing
damn saying give us a sub push real
quick
sam
can you give us a sub push real quick
what why what what do you mean what's
going on
for a video classic like if you haven't
subscribed consider doing so
hey if you guys like these videos hit
that subscribe button it's a once in a
lifetime opportunity you either hit it
or you don't
so jake is about to go on and do his
presentation but what they're going to
do is introduce this escort or digital
they're going to play our channel
trailer just so maybe some more people
can get familiar with the type of work
we do and then jake's gonna go on and do
his presentations
people got laptops out and stuff here
that i mean this is this is pretty
serious people are here to learn
hey there's my friend here's my friend
john i'll talk to you later hi hey hey
friend in case you need some smiles to
cut the jitters yes this is my buddy
jake we've had some really cool slumber
parties in utah and he's going to talk
now great actually i had a slumber party
at my house and at the space station and
put a giant hole in my space station
uh welcome to the the the stage here jay
from corridor digital
so jake here is did i get my mic
uh how's everybody doing you know before
i begin i'd like to get a feel for who
of you out there are creators
versus brand new so if i see a show
hands for creators
the way that each of these platforms
lives now is
[Music]
you know a lot of people say that these
speaking engagements are about telling a
group of people that may benefit from
your knowledge things that they want to
know
but really it's about the swag bags all
about the goody bag at the end of the
day
[Music]
it's the first year ever that the
seminico channel has not deleted raw
footage thanks western digital for
sponsoring our previous videos
thankfully we're out of contract with
them so we can get whatever we want
okay so the moment we disconnect this
old one it's going to disconnect
everybody on the network that means
everybody's going to have to stop
working for a little bit so what we're
going to do is we're going to disconnect
this one connect all the wires up into
this one so we switch over to this
everything should start working after
that and then that way everything will
be switched over to the 10 gig switch
streamline 10 gigabits we need to take
down the internet okay you're telling me
you got this figured out right
[Music]
[Applause]
where's the internet
yeah what happened what's going on
where's the internet where's the
internet where'd it go
you guys done yet no i do all the work
like more colors means more internet
yeah it does okay
oh wow this is so it's like a monolith
of power now that's the side panel here
now this is like it's like a tv here so
how much ram is in there there's 256
gigs of ram holy that's only filled up a
third of the way that's only fill up a
third of the way that motherboard is
insane
this is nuts so you want to turn it on
look at that that ain't gig it's set to
turn on every no matter what like if the
power dies will turn itself back on
okay this thing's so nuts
sorry yeah there's just so much to like
look at
so we also got six
six 10 gig ports coming out
at max up to six people can be pulling a
file from it at one time without slowing
down that's crazy my analogy was way
slower my computer is green currently
that's your computer right here yeah oh
you got your fiber optic finally yeah so
that must be me right here yeah probably
that's me
working on red footage this could be
super fun like having it in full
resolution
and playing back in full resolution all
you just need is another
lg 4k tv that's exactly what we need so
we just need 4k monitors i guess
keyman's just finished setting
everything up here the network is
running along beautifully everything is
incredibly mind-meltingly fast so i want
to take a moment here not only to thank
you immensely for helping us make better
films helping us edit at the speed of
thought you're actually changing quite
extensively how we work here and yeah
for sure it's a beautiful thing thank
you so much no problem but i also want
to take a moment to talk to you and
about what kim does kim's company is uia
solutions and if you are a creator a
studio a filmmaker really anybody that's
needing a centralized storage for data
that needs to be fast and speedy and
reliable kim is your man what we have
set up here it's a relatively complex
system of course they can get way more
expensive than this or less or less it's
a sliding scale but don't hesitate to
reach out if you are somebody who's
looking to build a reliable way to edit
across multiple computers quickly
efficiently
and without losing your data
all right guys time for that ribbon
cutting ceremony i'm going to select the
entire raid i'm going to drag it onto
the new one boom
boom
now i see our other rate is not actually
10 gigs so it's not going to go that
fast
12 terabytes at 109 megabytes per second
so
did you if we were doing this on a new
server at 10 gigabit speeds it only
takes two and two and a half hours
right now it's gonna take yeah this is
gonna take 26 hours
subscribe if you're not subscribed
already
next time i'll show you how to make
money on youtube